joe biden speaking this isn't today's
event but let's just listen to it
closing out
20 years we remain committed to ensuring
that afghanistan never again
provides a base for terrorist attacks
against the united states and our
partners in our interest
our european partners have also stood
with us to counter isis
just this week nato defense ministers
endorsed significant expanded
training and advisory mission in iraq
which will be vital to the ongoing fight
against isis
we cannot allow isis to reopen and
regroup and threaten people in the
middle east in europe and the united
states and elsewhere
and while the united states is
undergoing a thorough review of our own
force posture
around the world i've ordered the
halting of withdrawal of american troops
from germany i'm also lifting a cap
imposed by the previous administration
and the number of u.s forces
able to be based in germany this doesn't
sound good i know
i know the past few years have strained
and tested
our transatlantic relationship but the
united states is determined
determined to re-engage with europe to
consult with you
to earn back our position of trusted
leadership
earlier today as was referenced i
participated in the first meeting
of the g7 leaders where i spoke about
the dire need to coordinate
multilateral action to address covet 19
the global economic crisis and the
accelerating climate crisis
and so much else achieving these goals
is going to depend on a core strategic
proposition
and that is the united states must renew
america's enduring
advantages so that we can meet today's
challenges from a position
of strength that means building back
better our economic foundations
reclaiming our place in international
institutions
lifting up our values at home and
speaking out to defend them around the
world
modernizing our military capabilities
while leading
with diplomacy revitalizing america's
network of alliances and partnerships
that have made
the world safer for all people
you know i hope our fellow democracies
are going to join us in this vital work
our partnerships have endured and grown
through the years
because they are rooted in the richness
of our shared
democratic values they're not
transactional
they're not extractive they're built
on a vision of a future where every
voice matters
where the rights of all are protected
and the rule of law is upheld
none of this has fully succeeded in this
none of us has fully succeeded in this
division we continue to work toward it
and in so many places including in
europe and the united states
democratic progress is under assault
i've known for i know many of you for a
long long time
and you know that i speak my mind so let
me be very straightforward with you all
we are in the midst of a fundamental
debate about the future and direction of
our world
we're at an inflection point between
those who argue
that given all the challenges we face
from the fourth industrial revolution
through a global pandemic
that autocracy is the best way forward
they argue
and those who understand that democracy
is essential
essential to meeting these challenges
historians are going to examine and
write about this moment
as an inflection point as i said and i
believe that
every ounce of my being that democracy
will and must prevail
we must demonstrate that democracy can
still deliver for our people
in this changed world that in my view is
our galvanizing mission
democracy doesn't happen by accident we
have to defend it
fight for it strengthen it renew it
we have to prove that our model isn't a
relic of history
it's the single best way to revitalize
the promise of our future
and if we work together with our
democratic partners
with strength and confidence i know
we'll meet every challenge and outpace
every challenger you know we must
prepare together
for long-term strategic competition with
china
how the united states europe and asia
work together to secure the peace
and defend our shared values and advance
our prosperity across the pacific
will be among the most consequential
efforts we undertake
competition with china is going to be
stiff
that's what i expect and that's what i
welcome
because i believe in the global system
europe and the united states together
with our allies in the indo-pacific
worked so hard to build over the last 70
years
we can own the race for the future
but to do so we have to be clear-eyed
about the historic
investments and partnerships that this
will require
we have to protect we have to protect
for space
for innovation for intellectual property
and the creative
genius that thrives with the free
exchange of ideas in open democratic
societies
we have to ensure that the benefits of
growth are shared broadly and equitably
not just by a few we have to push back
against the chinese government's
economic abuses and coercion
that undercut the foundations of the
international economic system
everyone everyone must play by the same
rules
u.s and european companies are required
to publicly
publicly disclose corporate governance
struck two corporate government
structures
and abide by rules to deter corruption
and monopolistic practices
chinese companies should be held with
the same standard we must shape the
rules that will govern
a lot of toxic technology and the norms
of behavior in cyberspace
artificial intelligence biotechnology
so that they are used to lift people up
not used to pin them down
we must stand up for the democratic
values
and make it possible for us to
accomplish any of this
pushing back against those who would
monopolize
and normalize repression
you know this is also uh this is also
how
we're going to be able to meet the
threat from russia
the kremlin attacks our democracies and
weaponizes corruption to try to
undermine our system of governance
russian leaders want people to think
that our system is
more corrupt or as corrupt as theirs
but the world knows that isn't true
including russian's own russia's own
citizens
putin seeks to weaken european the
european project
and our nato alliance he wants to
undermine the transatlantic unity
and our resolve because it's so much
easier for the kremlin
to bully and threaten individual states
than it is to negotiate with a strong
and closely united
transatlantic community that's why
that's why standing up for the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
remains a vital concern for europe and
the united states
that's why addressing recklessness
russian recklessness and hacking into
computer networks
in the united states and across europe
and the world has become
critical to protecting our collective
security
the challenges with russia may be
different than the ones with china
but they're just as real it is not about
pitying east against west
it's not about we want a conflict we
want a future where all nations are able
to freely determine their own path
without a threat of violence or coercion
we cannot and must not return to the
reflective opposition
and rigid blocks of the cold war
competition must not lock out
cooperation on issues that affect us all
for example we must cooperate
if we're going to defeat covet 19
everywhere
my first presidential national security
memorandum focused on
surging health and humanitarian
responses to defeat covert 19
and to better prevent and prepare for
the next pandemic
today i'm announcing that the united
states
is making a two billion dollar pledge to
kovacs
i did read that some additional two
billion dollars
to urge others to step up as well yet
even as we fight to get out of the teeth
of this pandemic
the resurgence of ebola in africa is a
stark reminder
that we must simultaneously work to
finally
finance health security strengthen
global health systems
and create early warning warning systems
prevent
detect and respond to future biological
threats because they will
keep coming we have to work together
to strengthen and reform the world
health organization
we need a un system focused on
biological threats
that can move quickly to trigger action
similarly we can no longer delay
or do the bare minimum to address
climate change
this is a global existential crisis
tell that to ted cruz we'll all suffer
we'll all suffer
the consequences if we fail cancun
cruise we have to rapidly accelerate our
commitments to aggressively curb our
emissions and to hold one another
accountable
for meeting our goals and increasing our
ambitions
that's why as president i immediately
rejoined the paris agreement
and as of today the united states is
officially once again a party
to the paris agreement which we helped
put together
on earth day i will host a leaders
summit
to help drive a more ambitious actions
among the top emitters including
domestic climate action here in the
united states
i am grateful i'm grateful for europe's
continued leadership on climate issues
over the last four years together
we need to invest in the technological
innovations that are going to power
our clean energy futures enable us to
build
clean energy solutions to global markets
the threat of nuclear proliferation also
continues to require
careful diplomacy and cooperation among
us
we need transparency and communication
to minimize the risk of strategic
misunderstanding or mistakes
that's why the united states and russia
notwithstanding other competition
extended the new start treaty for an
additional four years once i came
i was sworn in that's why we said we're
prepared to re-engage in negotiations
with the p5 plus one on iran's nuclear
program
we must also address iran's
destabilizing activities across the
middle east
and we're going to work in close
cooperation with our european and other
partners as we proceed
we'll also work together to lock down
fissile and radiological material to
prevent terrorist groups
from acquiring and using them
look the range of challenges europe and
the united states must take on together
is broad and complex immediately i'm
eager to hear niggered here next
from my good friends and outstanding
leaders
senator merkel about her thoughts on the
way forward together
so let me conclude with this we cannot
allow self-doubt to hinder our ability
to engage each other
or the larger world right the last four
years
have been hard but europe and the united
states
have to lead with confidence once more
with faith in our capacities a
commitment to our own renewal
with trust in one another and the
ability of europe and the united states
to meet
any challenge to secure our futures
together
i know we can do this we've done it
before
just yesterday after a seven month
300 million mile journey
nasa successfully landed the
perseverance rover on mars
huge it's on a mission of exploration
with elements contributed by
contributed by our european partners to
seek evidence of the possibility that
life beyond our planet
and the mysteries of the universe over
the next few years
perseus has been recalled but
perseverance
will range and collect samples from the
red planet
and pile them up so another
mission and rover envisioned as a joint
effort between nasa and the european
states asian space agency
will retrieve this trove of scientific
wonders
and bring it home to all of us can you
imagine
that's what we can do together if our
unbound capacity is to carry us to mars
and back
don't tell us anything else they tell us
we can meet
any challenge we can face on earth
we have everything we need i want you to
know the united states
will do we'll do our part we'll stand
with you
we'll fight for our shared values we'll
meet the challenges of this new moment
in history
america is back so let's get together
and demonstrate to our great great
grandchildren when they read about us
that democracy democracy
democracy functions and works and
together
there's nothing we can't do
so let's get working thank you all very
much
so i wasn't actually planning on um
uncovering this
uh really what we're here for is the
press briefing scheduled
for 10 minutes from now covet 19 update
is going to be very very interesting but
this is joe biden's presentation
remotely
he's doing it cyberly today for the
munich security conference
and very interesting so that is over uh
this stream has concluded and we are
going to be hearing
from dr fauci very very soon
and i think that's a great thing we'll
go over coveted numbers momentarily
i do want to thank
six people who grabbed twitch subs while
president biden
was speaking and i also want to say a
big thank you to rodolfo sanchez
and jason murray signing up at
joinpacman.com and supporting the stream
today
uh very very exciting stuff all right
let's get to some of these super chats
that came in
isaiah says website says human error
must be the coupon code
no no chakaseki says i'm amazed at the
universal condemnation of
flying ted after his shameful lies and
changing narrative
can his humiliation get any worse
knowing fled cruz's luck it will
yes i think that this isn't this isn't
the bottom
for uh cancun cruz david i laughed so
hard when you powerfully timed the ymca
song at the inauguration and still do
every time keep up the good work thank
you
have i seen my ra rating on wikifeet the
proletariat wants to know
i'm told it's one of the highest ratings
ever seen on wikifeet i'm told my
my feet have scored very very strongly
on wiki feet that's my belief so the
vatican
vaccine mandate lol yeah let's i
actually have
um i i tweeted about this this morning
that kooky trumpist madison cawthorne
who's a member of congress look at what
he tweeted so here's the story
vatican employees who refuse to get the
covid 19 vaccine will be fired now
vatican is of course an independent
uh territory within italy it is sort of
like a country
it has nothing to do with american law
and madison cawthorne says
this doesn't sound legal i didn't know
he was an expert on vatican
law i thought his specialty was podiatry
this doesn't sound legal one shouldn't
be forced against their will to be
vaccinated
the vaccination is there for those who
want it are in need of it due to medical
vulnerabilities
dude it's a different country what are
you even talking about
um it it's just shocking and
he's a lawmaker in the united states oh
god
not this again all
[Laughter]
oh man not that again anyway uh okay so
that's that and we're standing by for
for the press briefing very good
um so that's yeah that's madison
cawthorne
by the way thanks for the perfect stream
david's the youtube experts all agree
thank you
marianne says david we cannot begin to
understand how much biden's words and
attack on one is an attack on all mean
to estonia latvia and lithuania today
free countries but they are still being
bullied by russia yes and i saw that
firsthand when i visited estonia not
long ago
uh al says wake up sleepy joe paul sent
20 bucks and retracted his message
and scott says i just spent a fortune on
getting alfajores both havana
and handmade ones shipped they better be
strong and outstanding or all be mad
they will be
they will be don't worry about it okay
listen
at this point it's time for the doom and
gloom
fudd fear uncertainty and doubt on covid
to stop
the correct approach now is cautious
optimism
the vaccines are pretty good against the
variants
they're being distributed increasingly
quickly
case numbers are collapsing down
71 on average over the last
um since the 12th i guess in about the
last five weeks
these are really good numbers deaths
while still
tragically high are down more than 30
percent
on average now the vaccine rollout
continues we are now averaging 1.6
million doses a day and that will
continue climbing
we're about to get the approval of the
johnson and johnson vaccine
i'll be going for my second dose
friday um things are improving
okay and while it is still insane that
we are losing 2500 people a day
the the path is the correct one and i
will
soon be in cancun if you can imagine
that no that's a joke
that's not that's not for real uh no but
things are improving dramatically
and um we are uh
let let's just let the data guide us
let's continue being safe let's continue
doing all the right things the israeli
data tells us
that uh these these vaccines really are
uh
incredible okay all right
um let's do the requisite poll
do people want me to do a troy york
voicemail today he hates the show but
calls in every day i'm pasting the poll
in twitch
i'm also going to paste the poll uh
in youtube you can start voting now the
first time
we did this uh it was two-thirds
in favor of troy york voicemails the
second time we did this it was only 5347
in favor of troy york voicemails so this
could be
um reduced dramatically we might
actually get a no today
um with the first hundred votes 60 40 in
favor
60 40 in favor uh with only a hundred
a hundred votes in so far but these can
keep coming in 59
in favor after 200 votes
this is democracy folks this is
democracy in the meantime i'll read a
few other super chats
on top of all that's wrong with cancun
cruz he left his dog under freezing
temperatures while vaccinating vile
repulsive and completely sick
yeah and i read his dog's name as
snowflake
chakaseki says got my second dose
prepare for some mild fever chills and
myalgia
tylenol and hydration are your friends
yeah listen chakaseki really needed the
vaccines because
he's a radiologist so he can sit at home
and look at his computer screen that's
very very high risk
that's a joke every medical professional
should get it everybody should get it
we love chaka seki thanks to stacy
martin
for subscribing at joinpackman.com
with 400 votes counted
59 percent want the troy york voicemail
let's do it since we are short on time
today because the press briefing starts
soon
here is the latest troy york voicemail
oh sorry guys i had it muted let me
unmute
here we go again um
i didn't appreciate what you said about
rush limbaugh
you know when i said i don't take
pleasure in anybody's illness or death
that's what you didn't appreciate
you you call them a right-wing radical
well you know what
some people would call you an extremist
left-wing radical so what
i i somebody now people have taken to
calling the voicemail number whenever i
play a voicemail
and even though i don't have do not
disturb on that's gonna ruin the
voicemail segment if people are gonna
start calling in every time
there it is again i'm gonna have to
figure out how to turn that off
um because i have do not disturb
on i don't know that there's any other
yeah let's see
always you okay
turn on the devices oh here's a setting
got it i just found the setting
beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful we fixed it um okay
unmute and let's continue
active rush limbaugh had for this nation
and talk radio and the industry
uh without this world it was historical
groundbreaking you know you
you were not alive or you might have
been in argentina or even
i've never been to venezuela israel uh
when russia limbaugh made it big so
maybe you don't quite
have an understanding of the impact that
the importance of rush limbaugh and
oh i know the importance he participated
in the dramatic radicalization of of the
airwaves
what he did for your industry i mean
you're for someone who's on the radio
you may not agree with this politics but
you you're just a partisan hack if you
think there's something
wrong with listen rush limbaugh did a
segment where he would celebrate the
death of aids victims
there's no equivalent that i'm doing on
this show
rush limbaugh gleefully celebrated the
death of ruth bader ginsburg
there's no left-wing equivalent that i'm
doing on this show
it wasn't a great moment that trump gave
rush limbaugh the medal of honor
then you're you're just a left-wing
communist socialist heck
right okay anyway so there's the troy
york voicemail you know not making any
relevant points
here's an interesting um super chat from
vincenzo dukes who says my parents are
under the impression covet cases are
going down because previous testing
sites are now vaccine sites is this even
possible
no that's that's a false thing that's
spreading um one of the important things
to look at is the positivity rate on
tests
um if the if testing was being cancelled
you would see um
people who are disproportionately sicker
be tested and the positivity rate would
go up but fortunately the positivity
rate is actually going down
so no we really are seeing fewer cases
in the united
states that's a good thing all right
very very important to know that
okay so we've gotten that out of the way
uh i had a couple of other things
oh yeah people asking about repeater
repeater hasn't called in for a long
time
um let me see here
let me see if i have anything from
repeater
nope doesn't look like it yeah we
haven't heard from repeater for a while
repeater is the guy who just repeated
the exact same voicemail
dozens of times in a row nothing nothing
from him at all
okay thank you to tlago mars
ellis gordon z hall
and a bunch of other people uh 10 twitch
subs
just dropped right in putting us at 19
today
we are standing by for a coronavirus
press briefing from the white house and
i'm very much looking forward to hearing
about vaccine insights
variants and a number of other things as
i was mentioning the israeli data
is giving us incredible insight into the
power of these vaccines study in israel
shows pfizer vaccine 85
effective after first dose now of course
get your second doses the protocol right
now is two doses
but what is very interesting is that the
more we learn about the vaccines the
more we realize
you could be vaccinating twice as many
people and
spreading out that second dose until
there's more supply
in two months three months this is not
me saying do any of this it's just
the data is starting to point in this
direction the fda approved protocol as
you get two doses 21 days apart with
pfizer
28 days apart with moderna i'm not
suggesting
anyone do anything different it's just
an idea now because if indeed
the difference between one and two doses
is 85 to 95
uh protection you could even more
quickly roll out first doses uh but this
this is something the fda
is going to look at um absolutely
incredible
incredible numbers that we are seeing
here overall infections including
asymptomatic reduced by 75 of course
i i appreciate that public health
experts are being cautious and saying
we don't yet know if the vaccine reduces
transmission
but it's logical to expect that the
vaccines would reduce transmission
and early data that has not yet been
peer reviewed and published i'm being
careful here
um points in that direction and that is
all extraordinarily good news
extraordinarily good news all right um
oh okay here we go thank you for joining
our covid 19
response briefing first
i want to start by saying that our
hearts go out to the people in texas
louisiana and across the country who've
been impacted
by the severe weather this week now i
want to give an update
on how severe weather across the country
has impacted vaccine deliveries and
administration
it has and how we intend to catch up
right here as of now
we have a backlog of about 6 million
doses due to the weather
all 50 states have been impacted the six
million doses represents
the six million doses represents about
three days of delayed shipping
and many states have been able to cover
some of this delay with existing
inventory
so let me first walk you through the
situation and then tell you how we
as an entire nation will have to pull
together to get back on track
there are three places along the
distribution chain that have been
impacted
by the weather first
fedex ups and mckesson our logistics and
distribution teams
have all faced challenges as workers
have been snowed in and unable to get to
work
to package and ship the vaccines kits
and the required diluent second
road closures have held up delivery of
vaccines
at different points in the distribution
process right
between manufacturing sites to
distribution
and to shipping hubs third
more than 2 000 vaccine sites are
located in areas
with power outages so they're currently
unable to receive doses
triple whammy general purna's guidance
to the team
was to ensure safety of personnel
preservation of the vaccines and
supplies
and constant communication with the
states
because of 72-hour cold chain
constraints
we don't want to ship doses to those
locations
and have them sitting at a site where
they might expire
so the vaccines are sitting safe and
sound in our factories and hubs
ready to be shipped out as soon as
weather allows
now as weather conditions improve we're
already working to clear this backlog
1.4 million doses are already in transit
today
and we anticipate that all the backlog
doses
will be delivered within the next week
with most being delivered
within the next several days and we
expect we will be able to manage both
this backlog
and the new production coming online
next week beautiful
with everybody's hard work and
collective effort
we will be able to catch up but we
understand this will mean
asking more of people ups
and fedex both will support saturday
deliveries tomorrow
nice we are working with the
jurisdictions to see which ones are able
to
take saturday deliveries
the packaging plant for modern vaccines
is just now coming online roads are
being cleared for the workforce to leave
their homes
they are working today through sunday to
package the backlogged orders
and will put the vaccines and ancillary
supplies on aircraft on sunday night
for monday through wednesday delivery
as we get back on track we're asking
states sites and ventilate and
vaccinators to help us catch up
and to get americans vaccinated
we know many americans are awaiting
their second dose
and many more their first dose
we're asking vaccine administration
sites to extend their hours
exactly even further i was going to say
20
go 24 hours and offer additional
appointments
and to try to reschedule the
vaccinations over the coming days and
weeks
right as significantly more supply
arrives
states and vaccination sites are going
to want to be prepared for the
additional volume
whatever reduction we see in our seven
day average
this week in vaccinations
from the weather if we all work together
from the factory all the way to the
vaccinators
we will make up for it in the coming
weeks
i want to personally thank the men and
women who have continued to keep our
operations up and running throughout
this storm
and have been working 24 by 7 with the
states
and with local vaccination sites
and my thoughts remain with all of those
impacted
i'll be happy to answer any questions
about this topic
but before we turn it over to dr
walensky and dr fauci
i do want to briefly touch on our work
to stand up more
federally run sites right even as we
manage the weather
on the one hand we are pushing ahead
with plans to get more vaccines
to more places to get more americans
vaccinated
today i'm pleased to announce we'll be
opening five
additional vaccination centers one in
pennsylvania
and four in florida in florida
there's an emergency in florida four
major new
community vaccination centers in
partnerships with the state
in orlando miami jacksonville
and tampa sites will have the capacity
to vaccinate a total of 12 000
individuals
per day in total in pennsylvania
we're announcing a major new community
vaccination center
at the pennsylvania convention center in
philadelphia
this site will have the capacity to
deliver 6 000 doses per day
selection of all of these sites is based
on a cdc
fema framework that has been developed
to target vaccinations to those who are
most
vulnerable the goal is to launch
vaccination sites that use
processes and are in locations that
promote equity
and deploy the cdc's social
vulnerability index
the federal government will be deploying
teams immediately
to work hand-in-hand with state and
local jurisdictions
to get these sites set up and we expect
both to
we expect them all to be up and running
in the next two weeks
so that's a brief status from the white
house covert response team
here we'll have more announcements to
come
next week now with that i will turn it
over to dr wolinski
to overview the state of the pandemic
and beautiful this is what we need
data thank you so much i'm delighted to
be back with you today
i have new information to share from cdc
regarding ongoing safety monitoring of
the coven 19 vaccines but before i go
into those findings
i want to provide a brief overview of
the latest data on the pandemic
let's do it we continue to see a
five-week decline in covet cases with
cases decreasing
69 in the seven day average since
hitting a peak on january 11. i said 71.
the current
seven day average of approximately 77
000
cases is the lowest reported since the
end of october
but still higher than the height of last
summer's peak
like new cove 19 cases the number of new
hospital admissions continues to drop
the seven-day average of new admissions
on february 16th
7 200 represents a 56
decline since the january 9th peak
as i reported on wednesday the number of
deaths continues to fluctuate
the latest data indicate that debts have
declined modestly in the past week to an
average of approximately 2 700
per day these numbers are a stark
reminder of the thousands of lives lost
to this pandemic another reminder of the
devastating
impact of the pandemic has had on our
country was brought into clear view
yesterday
in a report released by the cdc on the
provisional life expectancy in the first
half of 2020.
the report found that life expectancy
was at its lowest
level in 15 years dropping by a
full year compared to the life
expectancy in 2019
this represents a substantial decline in
life expectancy in our nation
importantly like the populations most
heavily affected by this pandemic
the declines in life expectancy were
again most pronounced in certain racial
and ethnic minority groups the largest
declines in life expectancy
occurred in non-hispanic black persons
dropping 2.7 years
levels not seen since 2001
and hispanic persons had lost the second
largest
life expectancy dropping 1.9 years
these findings though not surprising are
sobering
and representative of the continued need
to
take this pandemic and actions to stop
the spread of covet 19 seriously
saying data now more than ever with
continued spread of variants that stand
to threaten the progress we are making
we must recommit to doing our part to
protect one another
wear a well-fitting mask social distance
avoid travel and crowds
protect practice good hand hygiene and
get vaccinated when the vaccine is
available to you
i also want to spend a moment talking
about vaccine safety
to date more than 41 million people in
the united states have received at least
one dose of the cova-19 vaccine
but we continue to hear that people
might be reluctant to roll up their
sleeve because they are worried about
adverse effects
i will reiterate the cdc is committed to
monitoring vaccine safety
and and frequently reporting on what we
know
today cdc is releasing a study in the
morbidity and mortality weekly report
that describes findings from our covet
19 vaccine safety monitoring
in the united states from december 14th
through january 13
2021. during the first month of
vaccinations approximately 1.6 million
people
enrolled in v-safe cdc's new phone-based
covet 19 vaccine safety monitoring
system
i'm on that among those enrolled 71
reported pain where the shot was given
34
reported fatigue and 30 reported a
headache
these are common with most vaccines and
they typically resolve within a day or
two of vaccination
it's important to know that about half
the people don't feel very well after
getting their second dose
this should not deter you from getting
your second dose but you need to have a
light day of activity
after getting vaccinated i have nothing
planned there were also
rare reports of severe allergic
reactions like anaphylaxis
a serious but treatable reaction in fact
there are
4.5 cases of anaphylaxis per 1 million
doses given during this time
a rate similar to what we've seen in
other common commonly used vaccines
in the first month of experience a total
of 113 deaths
were reported of which approximately 65
were among long-term care facility
residents
a thorough review of the available data
indicated that these deaths were not
related to the coven 19 vaccine right
and the death rate in this population
though truly sad and unfortunate was
consistent with the expected background
death rate in this demographic
key point i want to emphasize that we
have implemented
the most comprehensive vaccine safety
monitoring system
program in our history and the data
released from the cdc today are
reflective of this effort
we will continue to closely monitor
these events and report back
as further data emerge i want to be sure
that you know the facts
and not the myths about the vaccine
safety
about vaccine safety the fact is they
are safe
and they will save lives and that is why
we are committed to working with state
and local public health partners
as well as partners in the private
sector to support
getting people vaccinated as quickly and
as safely
as possible to help advance our
collective efforts to scale up vaccines
and communities
on monday cdc is convening a three-d
day virtual national forum on cova 19
vaccine
the forum will bring together a broad
range of governmental and
non-governmental partners to share
information
and best practices on how to build trust
and confidence in coving 19 vaccines
how to use data to optimize vaccine
implementation
and how to provide practical real world
experience on how to increase
vaccination capacity
in communities especially for those at
increased risk of cova 19
and for those who may face barriers to
vaccination
i'm excited about this form and the rich
dialogue it will stimulate and i invite
those who are involved in vaccine
efforts
to register and attend this important
meeting thank you
as always i look forward to your
questions but before that i'll turn it
over to dr fauci
indeed thank you very much dr wolinski
what i'd like to do is to just take a
couple of minutes very briefly reviewing
the status
of the vaccines and vaccine trials that
we have but then to as i've done in the
past
pick out a question that i believe is
being asked
more frequently to try and preemptively
address it and perhaps generate
some discussion with regard to the
trials that we have as you know
the u.s government had been involved in
the development of
and or facilitation of the testing
of three separate platforms represented
by six different companies you're all
aware
of the data of the moderna and the fisa
bio and tech
which have their eua now having shown a
94 to 95
efficacy wow right now as we speak
the data from the onsen study which as
you know
72 efficacy in the united st
uh efficacy against the variant but very
good
against severe disease that is being
reviewed
at the fda for the u.s data and uh
on february the 26th the fda
will consult with their uh independent
advisory committee their verpack and we
should be hearing from them
soon oh that's great with regard to the
astrazeneca
and the nova vacs those trials are both
fully enrolled
these are event driven decisions
so when they reach a certain amount of
events they will then look at the data
and make decisions as to whether or not
to go ahead with a request
for an eua so having said that
let me just now very briefly address a
question
that is a very relevant question that we
are now more commonly
being asked if you look at the existing
trials those have already gotten an eua
and those that we anticipate and hope
will get in the ua
when will we be able to say we can
vaccinate
children right children in the high
school range
and children in the elementary school
range beautiful
you know from fisa that they started off
with the trial
of 44 000 individuals down to 16 year
olds and then
progressed it down to 12 year olds
so what they're going to be going in in
april
starting in april they are going to be
studying
12 year olds down to five to six year
old
that will take likely one year to get
the the uh information on that like not
until the first
quarter however we anticipate data
on high school age individuals namely
individuals
12 years old to 17 years old by the
beginning
of the fall maybe not exactly coinciding
with the first day of school
but sometime in the fall we will have
that
moderna as you know started off with
already
18 year old they are now currently
enrolling
12 to 17 year olds so let me take a
moment
to explain the process of how you get
relevant information regarding these
younger individuals
this is good this is a representative
trial which very likely will
reflect other trials it's a 13 it's a 3
000 person trial so right off you're not
dealing with the 30 04 000 person trial
that gave the efficacy signal in the
original
moderna and pfizer study
what the trial is is the trial is
an is what's called a non-inferiority by
immunogenicity which is a lot of big
words to really mean
what they're asking is it safe in the
children
and does it induce an immune response
that's comparable or not inferior
to the immune response that we know is
associated
with efficacy in the other trials right
and that's the way that trial will go
and then
we're starting by the end of march they
will do what's called
an age de-escalation study
we're already enrolling on the 12 to 17
they will go to the six to 12 then two
to six
then six months to two years
again we will likely get information
for high schoolers at some time in the
fall but it is
i would say more than unlikely we will
not have data
on elementary school children until at
least the first
quarter of 2022 similar types of
approaches are being taken
by the other uh candidates the other
companies
namely j and j novovax and az
so the bottom line of all of this is as
follows
it is highly likely that sometime in the
fall
we will have data that will give us the
capability
of saying the safety and
comparable efficacy in children 12
to 17 18 years old again the final
decisions
we always leave to the fda i'm trying to
give you a road map of what
likely will happen but then also
with the studies that i just mentioned
to getting the
information to make the decision in
elementary school children
almost certainly will not be firmed down
until the first quarter of 2022.
it is what it is stop there and hand it
back to andy
thank you dr fauci okay we can take some
questions
all right first up we will have jonathan
conan huffington post
uh thanks for taking the uh question i
have a question about the
federal uh mass vaccination sites and
and
and how you're deciding where to do them
and setting them up how much of this is
states coming to you and saying
okay you know we need help with this
place or that place can you come in and
and set up a fema site how much is this
you
going to the states and saying hey it
looks like
you need some help here or we see that
you know the progress you know you're
not hitting enough of the
uh underserved communities so we think
you we want to do a site here and in
general has there been a kind of overall
50-state assessment of
how the states are doing it distribution
and where they need help have you done
something like that
some kind of comprehensive look yeah
thanks jonathan um
and i may ask dr wolinski to comment in
a second on how
the cdc thinks about the social
vulnerability
vulnerability index and places where um
we would like to target what i would
reflect for you jonathan is we have a
very healthy ongoing
dialogue with multiple participants in a
state
every week and there is a good give and
take
we are obviously looking for two things
as we select these sites the first
is how can we get get more people
vaccinated more quickly
the second is how can we get more people
vaccinated more equitably
those are the those are really the two
most important criteria
and so um having these conversations
these dialogues go back and forth
um we you know to give you know as an
illustration
um we may have a a governor says we're
very interested in this
and then when we work with the cdc and
with fema we may say
if we if we do something in this state
this is the location that we
think uh works best and makes sense and
then
we'll have it back and forth so it's
very collaborative uh
it's very positive uh dr wolinski
anything you want to add more
specifically
i i don't have a whole lot to add to
that um except to say that really it is
a collaborative we are doing outreach
and we are actually receiving we're
trying to um
incorporate what states specific needs
are
um we do look specifically at the social
vulnerability index of where
um these sites might go also the
population size so we can understand
exactly what the needs are in those
specific
sites so it's a it's a deep
collaboration um
and it looks both its whole social
vulnerability index
the outreach that's needed um whether
there's you know the size
as well as what um mobile units might be
needed as well
yeah yeah jonathan the federal state
partnership
to us is the key in the approach we
view ourselves hopefully as good
partners to the states
um and if they if they bring us
challenges uh our goal is to help them
solve them
not to reward or punish as i think um
has been a prior philosophy
let's go to the next question prior
philosophy
next we'll go to cheyenne hasselhoff abc
news
hi thanks for doing this um thanks uh on
school openings my question
is about 75 of schools that are
currently located in the red
zones which the cdc guidelines recommend
be
hybrid or virtual so i'm wondering how
in
april just about two months from now the
president
intends to make good on that promise of
full time
in in-person schooling well thanks for
that question i think
that that question actually allows us to
clarify a few things that i'm going to
turn to dr walensky
to do that yeah thank you for that
question the first thing i just want to
convey
is there are opportunities for in-person
learning at all stages of
all states of community spread um as
we've seen community spread coming down
and as we've seen our numbers improving
right now
um what i would invite the schools to do
we have actually seen um
many more communities leave the the red
zone and move into the orange zone which
actually has more opportunities for
in-school opening
um and for in-person learning so so our
numbers are coming down i would actually
invite
schools to lean in and to look at what
is needed so that um in the roadmap
to to try and get more and more children
back to school
and i want to just just to clarify
something you said and because
it's so important dr wolinski
is it possible if you are in the red
zone
even if things are improving is it
possible in to open schools under the
cdc's guidance
absolutely so in the in the area that
remain red and there are about
two-thirds of districts now although the
numbers continue to decline
and the numbers that remain read we um
say with universal masking
and physical distancing and
de-densification of classrooms there are
opportunities for in-person learning
as well as for middle and high school
learning and um assuming you're able to
to do the de-densification that we
suggest
great i think that's a really important
clarification next question please
next we'll go to brenda goodman at webmd
hi um i have a question about dosing
there have been several studies
published in the last couple of days the
dosing of the vaccines that is
um that have suggested that just a
single dose of the vaccine might
be highly effective after about three
two or three weeks
and i wondered if that had shifted dr
fauci if it
had convinced you that just a single
dose
of the of the mrna vaccines might end up
being effective
well if you're referring to the mrna
vaccine you're probably referring to a
recent
um israeli study that looked at the mrna
because the
extension of the time in a single dose
with az has also been discussed
but let me refer and just answer
directly your question
with the mrna we always look at data
very carefully and very seriously and we
evaluate it as it evolves
but if you look at the data from the
particular study
and then go back and look at why we
wound up with a prime and a boost
and for moderna as you know that's 28
days and for pfizer it's 21 days
and the reason is even though you can
get a fair degree
of quote protection after a single dose
it clearly is not durable we know that
the durability is not as much as the
durability that you would get
with the boost secondly if you look at
the difference
between the degree the the
the intensity of the response after a
first dose
and compare it to that of the second
dose the second dose
is 10 times higher in the sense
of level of neutralizing antibodies
which is one of the parameters
of immunity wow so again although the
numbers of a single dose
do look interesting the one thing we
don't know
is how durable it is and since it's
10 times less than the optimal dose that
you would get
you have to look at it from two
standpoints you remember we discussed
on one of these press briefings before
that the reason why you look clinically
and see
that despite the fact that there is a
maybe
five to six fold diminution in the
impact
of the antibodies that are induced by
the mrna
candidates it still is within the range
of protection the reason for that
is that the response following the boost
was so high
that even though you diminished the
efficacy down to about 50 percent
you still had rather good efficacy
against severe disease yeah this is a
good point if you get
if you just assign numbers and we're not
missing anything because we're paused
if you need a level of 500
to be protected against serious disease
to the south african variant
and normally the vaccine would give you
1200 against the main variant and only
600 against the south african for most
people it would still be enough to
prevent severe disease
so it's a variant issue to protect
against variant
the other issue that we need to take
into consideration
is if you do have a less than optimal
even though with numbers they look
reasonably good
but not as good as the optimal response
what could happen
theoretically is that because of the
immunological pressure that you see
on the virus you might actually
theoretically
be inducing more variance yeah you don't
want that there are a few scientific
reasons
why we feel given the information we
have right now
we will stick with the scientifically
documented
efficacy and optimal response
of a prime followed by a boost with the
mrna
dr fauci just a couple additional
clarifications you said something here
which is important for i think the
public to understand
if we do see more of the variant
present in this country do you feel
better
with people having two doses of these
mrna vaccine
or one
um andy thank you for the question i
i alluded to it but thank you for giving
me the opportunity to repeat it there's
no doubt about that that you have an
optimal response
when you're dealing with variance you
want enough of a height of a response
that even if you diminish it you don't
diminish it so much to get out of the
realm of protection
right number one number two if you do
have a less than optimum response you
could theoretically and
inadvertently be selecting
immunologically
for variance right thank you so so just
a couple things to emphasize here one is
um we want the public not to be confused
the recommendation from the fda is two
doses
just as it always has been um number two
um and i think this is a sort of more
macro point i invite
either dr faust or dr bolinsky to to
comment here
there are studies all the time there
there are pre-prints all the time there
are
real world evidence uh comes out all the
time and it will continue to happen
um the people at the fda
led by peter marks people like dr fauci
people like dr wolinski
marx i love looking at this data love
looking at these studies
but it's also important to understand
that that one study
even though it may look attractive if
it's in the public domain
and may capture a headline isn't always
what it appears to be and it is only one
study
so i think we've got the best people in
the world looking at this i feel very
confident
and uh and they'll look aggressively at
these studies
but i think it's important that you
people understand that
we're not going to be persuaded by one
study that happens to grab headlines
we here at the white house will of
course listen to whatever the scientists
have to say
and adjust accordingly but any anything
you would want to add to that doctor
well let's gear faji
yeah um andy you know thank you for
bringing that up and with regard to the
specific study and again i'm not
criticizing the study
because it's an interesting study and we
really do want to follow up on this but
in uh again this is a study that we
we were made aware of by press release
so it wasn't something that we had the
opportunity to look at all the data yet
but it's very interesting that it says
here at the end the results
might differ from others getting to the
point that andy make there are many
studies
the results might differ from others
because the subjects were largely
younger and healthier said one of the
authors
she also said the study couldn't confirm
how long the protection from one shot
would last
as most of the subjects received the
second shot
right so the the points that i made in
my explanation
to the person who questioned is actually
admitted to
by one of the authors thank you
beautiful thank you
next question please all right we have
time for one more question
last we'll go to yamiche alcindor pbs
yamiche
hi thanks so much for taking my question
i have two questions the first
is a lack of pharmacies and hospitals
providers in transportation has emerged
it's a significant concern in the
community's heart is hit by the virus
what's the plan and the timeline for
getting more vaccination types for areas
with inadequate health infrastructure
have you and has the government found
that that that's a a problem
an increasing problem when looking at
vaccine distribution
and the second question i have is on
life expectancy i'm wondering how
lasting
this change in life expectancy is do we
expect it to bounce back will it go
to or and what will it take if at all
for it to go back
up well let me take the first question
and dr bolinsky you can maybe
uh get this the second question on life
expectancy
there are a number of issues that you
point out
um that are access barriers
um including transportation including
the the clinical infrastructure and then
including i think it's important to
point out that even when there
is a local availability of vaccines
people from outside of these communities
outside of the hard-hit communities
come in make appointments and often
take some of those doses which you know
we shouldn't be surprised about it
happens in a shortage but we have to act
on it because we are purposely setting
up
both sites that are located conveniently
in these communities
there will be a series of announcements
over the next to call it week to ten
days
about some major things that we're doing
about transportation
um about um appointment
uh reservations and ensuring that that
those appointments
are are kept um certainly bringing
mobile vans
into the communities bringing federally
qualified health centers which are
ideally located
uh into into communities and then
uh and then assuring that we have um
all of the um the the things that that
end up becoming barriers which are
the hours people are open um the the
ability to get there and back
um and uh and some of the other things
yeah that's important as there are more
vaccines distributed
if you don't increase the number of
sites dramatically
you're gonna have to think about running
places what 6 a.m to midnight
they're getting in the way so i can tell
you that we are working these in detail
along with the states along with local
communities
they are i think it's safe to say that
if you don't do these things
you naturally end up with the people who
are getting hit hardest by the virus
also getting
the least access to the vaccine there
are some success stories
i think it's too early to report that we
figured this out i think it's a constant
battle
to be honest uh dr bolinsky anything you
want to either add to that and of course
the life expectancy question
great maybe i'll just move to the life
expectancy question i agree with you
entirely andy
um you know the the report from cdc
really only reported the life expectancy
loss from
from january to june the first half of
2020.
quite unfortunately i think we're going
to see again
a decrease in life expectancy once we
start looking at the entire year because
we do know that the hardest hit
demographic
and highest mortality rates have been in
the older populations
i think we're going to have a lot of
work to do in this country over the
years ahead to try and make up the
losses that we've seen with this
pandemic
and that is going to be including um an
investment in our public health
infrastructure and improving the health
of the entire nation and especially
in improving the health of um of the
ethnic and racial minorities that
took the hardest hit thank you dr
blenski
i want to finish where we started which
is
to thank everybody who is going to be
working over this weekend to catch up
from the weather-related events to thank
our partners in states and local
vaccinators for
extending their hours and increasing the
access
to folks to get their vaccines and to
assure people
that if their vaccine because of the
weather has been
their second shot has been delayed by
for a short period of time it is not a
problem
um that will be accommodated uh
completely
thank you all and hope everybody has a
nice weekend
all right so the big takeaways here um
the diminished vaccination because of
the weather will be made up for over the
next seven days
new federal sites the vaccines with two
doses
appear to be generally speaking
protective
enough against the variants to limit
severe disease
the question about preventing an
infection altogether is an open question
they didn't comment about that we still
don't know that as far as that goes
and don't skip second doses the big uh
the big takeaways thanks to angela
keeler for signing up on my website
also thanks for everybody who supported
via twitch like kieran live and
astrolycos capriani
uh t-man dinah kosper and all sorts of
other
usernames that i will persistently
mispronounce that does it for me today
we'll be back very soon with many more
things
upcoming